hello and welcome to this video playing
uh Noddy getting the winning the pod not
keeping the pawn even though a try
but Chevy six is a slightly slightly
dubious line but it is some it's a kind
of line that catches most white players
by surprise and they oftentimes don't
have really have a good recipe against
it so the surprise value makes up for a
lot
so like here know it gives me the
default point and it's quite generous
really thinking you were to just take on
c6 okay so if I take on d1 now I
probably have to do that
of course my development is not
fantastic really not okay this is a bit
I don't really like to do it but it it
makes my development a lot quicker
it was the IDM that I get the suspicion
before with the temple
I don't like to give him the total
bishop pair but yeah that's probably
what what I should do her look we can go
look PA down it's not clear that this
come on
that is the simple way to do it and now
still have to get rid of the rook the
rook dat would take check a7 not ideal
[Music]
maybe start with a six his god Bishop d6
now
yeah okay it's still it's so not a huge
issue I think if I get the King to age
first let's get the King to e8
okay rook the eight will not work ever
but maybe I can do something on the
seafoam Knight to e7 Knight to d5
something like that also have night Eve
form it's not clear though rope will go
to d3 then okay this is quite useful
anyway maybe if I go 95 and now then you
will take Knight e4 now this rook b6
wait if I do this
is a school movie bishop t 595 the rook
has no squares just has no squares if I
go King is seven he has to go Bishop e5
I think and then rook c5 attacking the
e5 pawn yeah I can't go to the seven it
doesn't that is quite okay the look is
totally stranded on d6
okay and I have to check with the porn
right he cannot move the rook anywhere
rook takes he could take twice take g7
which I don't want but this is fairly
convincing I think
going forward now needs to mate oops
well okay it was a loss ending
don't tell me you know let the clock run
down probably is okay yeah not shown and
my snatch this early porn but do I
definitely had some compensation there I
wonder if I ever was in some kind of
trouble weird person but they I think
they have some if they do that too often
then they get some kind of like bad
marks on fun leeches and they get bends
I think and this that happens now for
boarding too many games or leaving too
many games yeah here in the opening I
think yeah I'm probably okay but it's
not really a something that I know very
well I'm very certain that this should
be very fine for me just wonder what the
best way of playing is I mean this is
there the simplest approach just saying
okay I've got a pawn I've got no
weakness whatsoever and I can with
Bishop before developed with the tempo
in case of 95cm yeah I'm not sure to see
does he have enough there I could
absolutely no weakness which is a real
bonus a real asset I don't think it's
enough for what I mean I'm not I'm not
clear pong up or something but I don't
think it is sufficient for compensation
yeah
so Knight a three c5 yeah the engine
wants to go night
five yeah that makes sense I mean I'm
just I was just playing this over the
board not knowing I know that bit should
be six is an idea but I don't know it's
good yeah 95 definitely it's not helping
what I mean here you probably have to
take on c6 or but what does the engine
giving Bishop c4 yeah well we shall see
force also kind of kind of rotten right
now Queen d3 is some compensation okay
yeah okay but look at the game so yeah
yeah yeah it's not easy I mean maybe
rook c8 as the engine suggests our g6
not taking I just wanted to have simple
decisions which I get with this probably
it's not objectively best but it should
be okay castles yeah King e7 given by
the engine this I didn't like because
the bishop now has no good square but
probably it is never attacked is the
thing then this is may be preferable
ninety six and I just again took the
simple route but just snapping it off
yeah come on it's just it's the simplest
thing to do a loop t8 and I mean every
single trade is helping or ninety five
is stronger of course yeah that is a
mishap
I missed that this is quite a bit
stronger because now he has to take
almost a Lukasik and that develops me
the knight on d5 is very nice yeah this
is just a clean horn up and here this is
not as easy because I mean he has a bit
of space but I felt I was doing okay
first of all bring the king near the
action and then and then this regrouping
I think it was good 97
better it seems okay but it's not bad
right
who 95 is of course strong winds
materially medium
I was just spotting this thing with with
kini 7 and it does wind fairly
convincing them yeah rook takes should
win as well but then you have to deal
with this which is not necessary the
take where the pond is is still trapped
and yeah okay f6 was good but they want
what nothing white has nothing here can
just and now okay if you go back be
three Falls with check and this is not a
made but should win also quite easily
274 so doesn't have many squares and I'm
a huge chunk of pawns up probably the
opening line is dubious though if I if
you look at this again this has no good
squares it may be maybe this f3 and then
this is this thing this wouldn't be all
that bad but there is d5 I guess m5 as
an issue hmm that looks problematic yeah
it was an experiment that maybe could
have gone the wrong way
okay yes thanks for watching